tonight I want to speak to you about
what the United States will do with our
friends and allies to degrade and
ultimately destroy the terrorist group
known as ISIL
president Obama has effectively declared
war on the Islamic state in Iraq and
Syria announcing that we will degrade
and ultimately destroy Isis through a
comprehensive and sustained
counterterrorism strategy but here are
three reasons we should not be fighting
Isis in the Middle East and anytime we
take military action there are risks
involved
Warhawks such as Senator Dianne
Feinstein claim that the threat Isis
poses cannot be overstated that is
itself an overstatement
the FBI and homeland security both say
Isis is an incredible threat to the
American homeland the group may be great
at using social media to exaggerate its
power but estimates of its troop
strength range between 10,000 and 30,000
and most analysts talk about a core
group of just a few thousand fighters
and anytime we take military action
there are risks involved Isis controls
territory inside Iraq and Syria but even
President Obama concedes that Isis does
not currently pose a threat beyond that
region Iraq and Syria and their
neighbors including Turkey Iran Saudi
Arabia Jordan and the Kurds are the ones
that must deal with this problem Iraq's
army already has more than a quarter of
a million u.s. trained troops the
Peshmerga almost as many Iran's active
forces number over half a million and
anytime we take military action there
are risks involved in announcing bombing
runs and sending more American soldiers
to the Middle East President Obama not
only failed to call for congressional
authorization he neglected to discuss
any sort of exit strategy that's a
prerequisite for any responsible war
plan as important his definition of
success we will ultimately destroy Isis
he says is a goal nobody has ever
achieved against any terrorist group
let's be clear the u.s. should do
everything it can to defend its citizens
and its interests
but if the past dozen years have taught
us anything in Iraq and elsewhere it's
that war is more complicated than our
leaders ever want to admit and it's a
lot easier to start wars than to win
that or even know when they're over for
reason TV I'm Nikolas